a friend of mine works in the
entertainment industry he manages
comedians and tv personalities and he
puts on tours
both here in the uk and in the states
and he represents some quite big names
and one of the reasons he has such a
good reputation
in the business and why he's so well
liked by the act he's axe he manages
is his foresight
he can see when something's about to go
wrong often long before
anyone else can and is able to
either avoid whatever's coming or get
some damage limitation in place
but like everyone else in the in the
live entertainment industry
he has had a miserable year it's been a
tough year for lots of businesses but
entertainment has to be
among the hardest hit of all and
earnings for my friend have gone from
very nice thank you very much to zero
turnover has stopped and my friend will
be fine he's made good money over the
years
but it's still amazing watching an
industry
not even grind to a halt just halt
almost overnight and there have been
grants to help him out but i think
the most difficult thing has been to
deal with the false dawns every time
it's looked as though
there was finally a chance to get back
to normal and things were opening up
plans have been scuppered and all the
effort
that goes into putting on a show booking
the date securing the staff and crew
sorting out the publicity
the technicals meeting the new and
ever-changing
and often inconsistent regulatory
requirements let alone writing and
rehearsing the material
is suddenly torpedoed and so he now
lives in a
in a state of paranoia every time boris
johnson or the health secretary
make an announcement because he knows
the goal posts
are about to be shifted
but when kovid came along last year my
friend was i think probably one of the
quickest of anyone i knew to
see that the long-term dangers i had one
friend in new zealand
a bitcoin gazillionaire who'd been
warning me for weeks and had holed up in
his
mansion with a year's worth of supplies
but him aside
entertainment manager howard was ahead
of the pack
and he said to me i could see what was
coming
uh and he went on most of my money is in
property
but what i had in the stock market i
sold and the stock market is now
quite a bit up on where i sold but and
we were actually talking last monday
it's down two percent today
it's not looking good at all finally
people seem to be waking up
to the havoc this has caused in the real
economy now
howard is right stock markets do not
reflect what is going on in the real
economy and for the sake of clarity
i'm talking about the u.s indices as
well as those in the uk if stock markets
did reflect what was going on
they would be much lower howard's logic
is reasonable the real economy is
struggling especially in the industry he
works in
and so what he's immersed in and seeing
every day is not being reflected in
prices the chances of going back to
normal look
slim the virus is ongoing and the
ongoing reality is that the goal posts
could be shifted at any moment and any
recovery derailed
but there's one huge assumption that
howard is making without even realizing
it perhaps
he's assuming that money
is sound he's ignoring the fact that new
money is being created
every day whether by the issuance of
debt or by digital printing
and most of that money goes straight
into financial markets
some have access to the capital most
especially in the daily grind of the
entertainment industry
don't so money supply
may be tight in the foothills of
laughter but it isn't
at the corporate or government level it
is a two-tiered economy
he's on one tier and mistakenly assumes
all the other tiers are the same
they aren't now in the 1980s when
interest rates were in the five to ten
percent range people
saved their money in a bank or a
building society and they were paid
a reasonable level of interest now
with rates suppressed no such vehicle
exists
oops and the model of saving your money
in a bank or a building society is dead
what is even the point of a savings
account
most of us only have one out of legacy
banking may be maybe a great vehicle for
payments
but not for savings and so the stock
market especially s p 500
has become a savings vehicle when you
buy the s p
500 in part you're placing a bet that
the american economy is going to grow
and prosper
but you are also simply gaining exposure
to america's savings and while
interest rates stay low and money
creation is plentiful
and think of the money creation that
happens simply by leveraging gearing
money will make its way into the stock
market
and every time everybody earns anybody
earns anything
and saves that's money will make its way
into the stock market
furlough money they're paid will make
its way into the stock market that's not
supposed to be
what investing in a market is about
should be about understanding a company
and its chances
but with tracker funds etfs low interest
rates qe and all the rest of it
that is what stock markets have become a
savings vehicle
such is the economic distortion of
today's markets and one day
it will all go belly up of course but
that day
is not today famous last words
and you just need to see the spring with
which the s p 500 bounce back from last
monday's correction it was a
straightforward bounce off the 50-day
moving average in effect
so howard my canny entertainment manager
friend
is right markets do not
reflect what is happening in the real
world but what is happening
in the financial world is rather
different
and stock markets do reflect
that as long as there is money being
saved
or printed the s p 500 will have buyers
as long as there are buyers there will
be leverage
and leverage means more buying and it
will carry on
until it doesn't thanks very much for
watching
please subscribe to my channel and i'll
be back with another video
very soon until then cheerio
you